bonjour à 12,6 ergo rock alors [ __ ] je
n'étais pas prêt là je viens de rentrer
ça fait une heure trente que je suis
dans les bouchons parce que c'est noël
chants plein centre-ville du coup c'est
le bordel là je viens tout juste de
rentrer joue un petit tweet ou ergo
j'attends tes vidéos est tous pareil
pour aéro j'attends tes vidéos parce que
y'a ventures ngame what the fuck what
the fuck
et là je regarde et ya venture seng
emial de trailer je suis pas du tout
préparé j'ai pas préparé de scripts ya
rien je ne sais pas et on va faire une
petite réaction au trailer parce que il
le faut qu'on le découvre ensemble je me
suis toujours dit que je le ferais que
pour les gros événements les gros trucs
et la bonne chose car ça fait un moment
qu'on en parle et cetera va certainement
y avoir des théories à faire donc là mon
week-end je sais ce que je vais faire
dans mon week-end c'est ça que je veux
dire bref allez on va regarder le
trailer je peux plus attendre alors j'ai
un cas ce que tout péter parce que voilà
mon casque et cassé j'ai trop le sun
suis pas dans de bonnes conditions et
bref aller 3 2 1
s'est connecté
salut mais la botte si tu trouves cet
enregistrement
je ne veux pas que tu aies de la peine
la faim fait partie du voyage
pour info se retrouver à la dérive dans
l'espace sans aucune chance d'être
secoué
c'est plus marrant que ça en a l'air je
n'ai plus de provisions depuis quatre
jours d'oxygène saurait épuiser demain
matin pour tous
quand je me sentirai partir je sais que
je rêverais toi mais allez-vous nebula
parce qu'il n'y a que toi
[Musique]
[ __ ] ironman
la nuance
avec cette chose qu'il avait promis
un type
pour cent de tous les êtres vivants
on a perdu on a tous perdus
on a perdu des amis on a perdu de la
famille
part de nous mêmes
c'est le combat de votre vie
va réussir stif j'en suis certain parce
que je ne sais pas ce que je ferais si
on échoue
[Musique]
salut ya quelqu'un et c'est scott
langues
on s'est vus il ya quelques années à
l'aéroport en allemagne j'étais super
dense et un ancien message antoine je
suis sûr qu'on se connaît c'est la part
principale c'est moi quelqu'un peut
m'ouvrir ok alors il ya trop d'infos il
y en a pas assez du tout en fait c'est
what the fuck [ __ ] je m'y attendais
trop page savaient qu'ils sortaient
bientôt mais genre c'est vrai qu'on est
vendredi la [ __ ] l'amf h alors tony
sarr je comprends pas qu est ce qu il
faut tout seul nebula est censé être
avec lui
peut-être qu'elle l'a laissée pour faire
quelque chose d'autre je ne sais pas je
je je suis très troublé là je ne sais
pas trop
évidemment il rodman il va pas mourir
comme ça délaissée bout tout en ayant
faim etc va forcément quelqu'un y avoir
quelqu'un qui va le sauver mais qui
alors qui c'est la question parce que
personne n'est dans l'espace la partie
du là
dans nos héros donc je sais pas mais
c'est fort c'est qu'il va s'en sortir
peut-être une potentielle façon va y
avoir des héros qui vont mourir c'est
sûr et je parie que dans ce qu'on a vu
l'oeil
beaucoup de ces héros vont mourir
évidemment à ça fait trop bizarre de
voir une un trailer la dent fin et en
plus c'est ngame savait était supposé
mais on pensait pas que ça allait être
ça donc c'est pas annulation c'est ngame
du coup ouah donc c'est vraiment la fin
de l'histoire la fin du jeu oui il y
aura d'autres films et cetera
mais voilà quoi donc évidemment jeu là
le trailer je trouve qu'ils révèlent un
truc énorme et que ont théorisé que moi
perso j'ai beaucoup théorisé et que
c'était obvious voilà antoine on a
l'image de bruce banner avec l'image
d'antoine qui est absent voilà il a
disparu etc
et à la fin il revient en tant que que
il revient en gros voilà quoi il a ouvré
moi la porte c'était évident hartmann
singh clé scénaristique énorme
il a trouvé un moyen de sortir des
champs quantique comment peut-être grâce
à strange qui est revenu avec en forme
d'avenant de corps astral donc
certainement il va certainement revenir
grâce à ça donc c'est une certitude
voilà scott langue est une clé
scénaristique d'avengers 4 je pense que
tony stark aussi parce que justement il
est dans l'espace et il ya des failles
avoir un truc à faire dans l'espace
alors évidemment hockey y est revenu en
tant que rooney voilà on le voit avec
son sabre il revient en tant que rhône
un run in peut-être j'ai peut-être une
mauvaise prononciation plutôt ronin est
ok donc ça c'était vachement supposé
c'était vachement prévu et c'est plutôt
cool
par contre est-ce qu'il est là pour se
débarrasser des derniers agents d'hydra
un fait infiltrer dans le shield je ne
sais pas je suis incapable de vous dire
ce que
aux cayes devenu maintenant ronin a fait
durant toute la période où il ya eu la
guerre contre thanos et cetera alors ce
trailer
franchement il ya très peu d'infos
dessus on sent vraiment que là on est en
mode c'est la fin c'est le dernier
espoir c on est tous tristes on a trop
perdu etc
mais un truc qui m'intrigue vraiment
beaucoup c'est que steve rogers et
natacha sont en mode il faut qu'on
réussisse etc
ouais parce que si on échoue je vois pas
que je vois pas quoi faire et c'est
enfin ça veut dire qu'ils ont un plan
ils ont prévu un truc et notamment avec
scott
mais quoi mais quoi et c'est là que
que du coup je suis interpellé est ce
que c'est sur c'est le chant quantique
c'est sûr il ya un rapport avec le chant
quantique c'est le chant quantique la
solution scott langues
eli a la chance quantique c'est si scott
langue est là en tant que sauveur en
tant que clé scénaristique c'est obligé
que ce soit à cause du chant quantique
parce que bon se rétrécir je suis pas
sûr que ça puisse sauver l'univers donc
c'est forcément le champ quantique
captain marvel est lié aussi au chant
quantique ses pouvoirs qu'on a pas vu
dans le trailer d'ailleurs cessé s'est
pas fait par hasard je pense donc il ya
vraiment un truc je pense que l'histoire
va beaucoup se tourner autour de steve
et natacha qui sont plus que deux à
fonctionner ensemble
et puis du coup scott qui va se greffer
au truc il ya aussi banner mais je pas
pourquoi ils ont beaucoup montré steve
et natacha je pense que ça veut ça veut
certainement dire quelque chose
moi je suis partisan de ceux qui pensent
que steve va mourir je suis sûr steve va
mourir il va y avoir des conséquences
dans ce avengers va y avoir des morts
sinon ce serait trop a pyrène ce serait
trop trop facile j'ai envie de vous dire
va y avoir des conséquences est obligé
mois pour moi ironman et steve rogers
sont vraiment sur la sellette
ils vont être des personnages clés
certainement mais ils sont sur la
sellette et la halle trailer me fait
penser aussi que natacha peut-être quoi
donc qu'est-ce qui prévoit on ne sait
pas je pense que le voyage dans le temps
et quand même là je pense qu'ils aient
un rapport avec le voyage dans le temps
comme j'en parlais là dans ma dernière
vidéo qui vient de sortir
je sais pas quoi dire c'est ouf on
retrouve banner encore une fois un
bonheur qui je pense va être aussi un
gros monument de ce film parce que voilà
je pense qu'ils ont assez ridiculiser
hulk et banner je pense qu'ils vont
enfin quand même trouvé un petit terrain
d'entente et enfin en réussir à
fonctionner ensemble
je pense qu'il est temps maintenant de
réussir deux affaires ce à quoi tient je
m'attendais trop pas ce trailer et en
même temps ils montrent rien dit ou fait
c'est tout le monde est triste le monde
pleure je pense qu iron man je sais pas
et rodman je ne sais pas je pense pas
qu'il va mourir là dessus sur ce qui est
montré
mais je pense que ça veut peut-être
envoyer un message comme quoi ironman va
se sacrifier tête pour sauver la cause
et ça ne m'étonnerait pas du tout
j'avais un abonné je sais plus son nom
il m'avait proposé une vision est
incroyable comme quoi en fait
tony star sera un petit peu l'oncle
ben's pourquoi je dis oncle ben's ça
c'est du ris non j'ai pu donc le ben de
spider man
il est un petit peu comme l'oncle ben de
spider man en fait et c'est vrai que ça
c'est vraiment le cas s'il est un peu
comme un mentor pour spider man un peu
comme un oncle un père et je pense que
ça pourrait vouloir dire quelque chose
comme quoi peut-être ce tony stark
pourrait un moment tu es en sauvant
justement spider man
et je sais pas quoi dire de plus
franchement c'est juste une petite
réaction à chaud comme ça je suis trop
là je suis trop beaucoup trop perturber
la part ce trailer
bref je vais je vais essayer de voir ce
que je peux en tirer si je peut vous
sortir une petite vidéo théorie oui mais
je suis vraiment pas sûr y'a pas grand
chose dans ce trailer je vois le wakanda
aussi mail wakanda qu'est-ce que ça peut
bien vouloir dire le wakhan damas ils
sont un peu perdus je pense que et il
est mort ses fins black panthères
écoutez je pense qu'on va arrêter cette
vidéo là je suis très perturbé je suis
très heureux donc and games et valider
ces endgame bon en attendant je vous
fais des gros bisous alors oui petit mot
chaque commentaire qui parlera de ce
sommet parce que je peux pas faire
autrement je suis dans un 20 mètres
carrés donc je suis un espace très petit
c'est à dire que là il n'y a pas de
place en fait là genre il ya juste un
petit escalier pour que je puisse monter
là-haut dans le duplex et il ya rien je
peux pas mettre le sommier donc tous
ceux qui parleront du sommier et bah
écoutez ça donne une chance en plus apte
à nous de gagner
nous voilà vous êtes prévenus je vous
fais des gros bisous que le 'lion' alors
soit avec vous cet argot rock
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]